all right China hey Chyna
where'd you grow up where you from I'm
from Los Angeles I grew up and I guess
you can say between Highland Park area
and south-central
eighty's area on off a Holborn feet okay
mm-hmm tell me about your childhood he
had both your parents growing up um I
didn't have both of my parents on me my
mom and my granny my dad both when we're
on drugs my dad was on drugs so he was
in and out of jail so only my mom was
surrounding she was also on drugs in and
out of jail she's now deceased now so
when you have my dad living right now
who's never really around no not growing
up yeah how was your childhood childhood
was pretty rough I've been in foster
care being in some tough situations any
of you sir some abuse yes not abuse from
a parent but molested as a kid yes
that's like that and then what age were
you when you went on your own well I've
been on my own since I've being like 13
not so much into in the game of
prostitution but in the game of life
because like I said my mom was in and
out of jail so she would go to jail and
I would have to cash our County check
pay the bills have one of her friends or
tricks or whoever he was taking me to
civil brand to put money on her books so
I grew up kind of fast
I didn't get to go fast yeah not just
fast in the street just fast after the
meant for me being able to be the mother
of the cows because I have two younger
sisters
you do did you finish high school I did
finish high school I went back and got
my high school diploma I was a teen
parent so you know I went back at the
Teaneck I might see a child at what age
18 18 mm-hmm then prostitution started
for you maybe around 2023 I was growing
it was my choice my kid's father we had
broken up I had lost my job I didn't
know any other hustle I knew people that
was in the game like my sister she was
faster which was she was younger than me
so she taught me the game in the streets
of a bigger or learning the game and
stuff so yeah and then you so when you
started working you started working to
figure out yeah and did you work with
the pamper on your own some would not a
pimp maybe my own I have protection
because my family is from Hoover and
stuff so yeah powerful yeah I had little
protection a family and stuff and you
know area since the for you and then
today you're you're doing what I do a
little bit of everything I still if I
have I still turn dates I still get
clients and I'm fake not awful feeling I
ended once I met Bishop you know he
showed me a different way of working the
streets and doing different things you
know getting money in different ways
like you said like casinos and you're on
the internet and yeah he elevated
totally elevated the game and showed me
how to step my game up yeah so you're
more of a high-end yes yes version of
what I also interviewed before yes so
you'll go to the casinos in Las Vegas
and Las Vegas bicycles casino
Camas casino out here out here yeah
casinos in there hmm
and what kind of money will you making
tonight uh five hundred seven hundred a
thousand depending on with different
clients maybe two thousand you know
because I deal with the poker tables and
stuff you know the high-end class poker
tables and stuff so it depends a good
night mm a hundred bad night maybe 705
honey you know play every little bit
counts you know you're not gonna turn
down no money when you in need of it
yeah so you know how old is your child
huh I have a 21 year old a daughter a 18
year old daughter and I have a
two-year-old son did you raise all three
oh yes
they'll currently Raven yes yeah and did
you have the dad's help no dad's help
mom I'm always dated on my own with the
school for nursing the game has always
been there because that's that's how I
learn how to eat when I didn't have
anything so you know streetwise yeah and
how are your kids are doing fine oh yeah
they're doing good have you ever been
arrested never been arrested for a
prostitution I have people use my name
and stuff but me personally no never
been arrested like I said when I met
Bishop he changed the game I didn't have
you know all that different stuff
anymore so working the street is a very
different lifestyle than what you're
doing yes it totally Toby it's more
safer you know you the streets you never
know I've been got in the car and being
raped before and stuff and all that like
you know that's that's the reason why I
pray to God it could get me out of this
one Lord I won't do it like that no more
and he asked in my prayers you know I
met Bishop and he changed he changed the
game he showed me a different way to you
know present myself to dress two for
these client's yeah yeah your kids know
you do this yes they do but then they
don't because it's so you know but I
think Mike and my girls are older they
under
saying life they understand you know but
you know they know that you you know
they work right now so they know that
they're not going to just lay up they're
gonna you're gonna even have to get some
kind of money you think you want to
provide it going to school getting the
education which that's what they're
doing and also working when you were a
kid did you have dreams of doing
something other than like nursing yeah
but honestly I always kind of thought
about the prostitution like because I
had a cousin who was in the game named
Evan and as a kid she would come over
with these meat coats and Jiri and all
this stuff and you know it was kind of
aunts north to a young girl so you know
how do you think doing this for a living
has changed you I think it made me a
hustler you know and pushed to the
memory because you never know you know
my story making help somebody else
that's going through it I've been
through it and think why I all got to do
it like this no more you know cuz I've
been I'm sick of her I know how it is
it's rough you know that jumping in and
out of cars and all
like you know you find when you were
working the street if I figure out you
you would get more depressed or down on
your oh I had used ecstasy I started
using ecstasy and stuff yeah yeah
definitely but I was mentally and more
stronger to where I don't have to use
any drugs you know
Bishop told me that too I don't have to
use anything you know be more wise the
open and you know so you can understand
the game understand the knowledge that
you getting from the game so sorry drugs
are part of your life no I don't use any
dresses marijuana yeah yeah that's great
and you're saving money yeah it's kind
of hard saving money when every [ __ ]
you get you you know gotta pay bills
gotta do stuff
definitely definitely time definitely
saving money though where do you see
your life going oh my doing some
modeling and stuff I got some gigs and
casting agencies that's been hitting me
up target commercials and different
stuff you know so you've done some
modeling too yeah that's a matter what
was the worst the lowest point of your
life
well my mom passed yeah that hurt me
more than anything
because actually you're called like
you're on your own yeah because there
wasn't nobody else to depend on you know
but she was my back boss yeah
what advice would you give a young girl
who's looking to get into some this kind
of work
well people are going to experience
things on their own but I'll tell them
that find their self first before they
just decide to get in this type of work
like you know it's a lot of stuff and
people think oh all girls has been
molested are being abused or now
prostitutes and stuff what statistic is
true but you might can be the one to
change that you might be the one to say
hey I'm gonna do with a little different
I'm not going to use my body the way
everyone else is but at the same time
I'm not going to abuse my body
have you been in love before oh yes and
is this lifestyle of get in the way of
that you file oh definitely definitely
it's hard for a guy to deal with that
yeah it's hard for a guy to think that
you're serious or sometime with just
another man chest doesn't want another
man that you know that's someone else's
being but then you find guys that want
someone just because of who they've been
with or who they know or who they're you
know what's the most he ever made in a
night maybe like 2000 2500 they make
more money in the casinos in Las Vegas
yeah
casinos Las Vegas is easy money cuz you
know everyone there you know they just
want pleasure how do you do it you just
hang out all the time is sex and stuff
you know you just hang out in the bar
and look you stand by the tables not too
close maybe sit down have a drink myself
play a game you know cuz you'd be
surprised what a person to pay you for
you know I have people that want golden
showers and stuff like that no you get
that - yeah yeah you're on the high end
yeah yeah yeah fetishes with your toes
just you know want to rub your feet on
it on them so yeah a lot of times it's
not always sex it's more more of a
fetish with me it's an interesting world
isn't it
certainly is alright China well thank
you so much for sharing your story thank
you so much for having me
that's great
you